hey everyone let's solve another classic
leak code problem today longest
palindromic substring
so we're given a string in this case
b-a-b-a-d
and we want to return the longest
palindromic substring that exists
inside of here in this case there's
actually two
b a b as well as a b
a so we could return either of these and
that would be perfectly fine
now what actually is a palindromic
substring in the first place
basically it means that you know you
take b
a b if we wrote that in the reverse
order which would be
you know b a b it's the exact same
string
so like i usually do let's say you just
don't know how to solve
the problem well what's the most brute
force way you could do it
well you could say i'm just going to
check every single substring
in this original string and check if
it's a palindrome and get the longest
one
starting at b so i would check this i
could check this
i could check this this
and this right so every substring
containing this
original b and i want to check for each
of these
is it a palindrome or not and i would
repeat
that process with every character right
so for this a
i'd get every substring
and basically keep doing that now the
question is
for a string for example b a b
how what's the time complexity to even
check if it's a palindrome well we'd
have to scan
through the entire string right so for
any given sub string
to check if it's a palindrome it's going
to take
linear time complexity so let's say
n right now how many sub strings
do we actually have to check
n squared because we're checking every
single substring containing every single
character
so to check if a string is a palindrome
we have to do
we have to do a linear scan and we have
to do that for every single substring
so then that's going to mean that the
overall time complexity of this brute
force approach is going to be big
o n cubed so the question is how can we
do
better well it it actually involves
understanding how to actually
check if a substring is a palindrome or
not
for again let's look at bab we can check
if it's a palindrome
by starting at the outside and comparing
these characters
and as long as they're equal we'll keep
going until we get to the middle
and then we'll check and then we'll know
okay it's a palindrome but we could also
do it another way
we could start at the middle and then
expand outwards
and and check if it's a palindrome that
way so
which one of these is going to help us
more well let's think about this
let's say i wanted to know for this b
what's the longest palindrome where this
b is the center of the palindrome
well there's no character to the left of
it so it's just going to be this
character
this or this b itself right so it's just
one
what about this a well let's let's start
expanding there is a character to the
left and there is a character to the
right and they happen to be equal
so the longest palindrome with this a at
the center
is going to be a length 3 and it's going
to be
b a b notice how if we do it this way
for each character we're going to
consider it the center and we're going
to keep expanding outwards
we're going to take each character so
that's going to be n and to expand
outwards for each character it's going
to be n again
so for this way the overall time
complexity
is going to be o of n squared so that's
kind of
clever right like a little a subtle
difference of how we check if it's a
palindrome
can really improve the time complexity
but hold on
there's one edge case that we're missing
when we take
one character and expand outwards from
it like for this b
we're getting palindromes that are of
odd
lengths they've conveniently shown us
this example
where the longest palindrome is actually
even so how are we going to check
even palindromes well that's just a
slight edge case
that we can easily add to our solution
so we just have to remember to handle
this edge case when we're implementing
our code
okay so let's get to everybody's
favorite part the code
so i'm gonna initialize the result as an
empty string because you know that's
just a good default case
we'll get the the longest length
initially set to zero
now we're gonna go through every single
character or
rather every single position in this
string
considering it to be the center so first
let's check
odd length palindromes
so i'm going to have a left and right
pointer these left and right pointers
are going to be initialized
to i which is our center position
right now while my left and right
pointers are
inbound
as well as while this is a palindrome so
i want to check that the left and right
are equal to each other
remember we're starting in the middle
and expanding outwards
so while this is the case we know it's a
palindrome so we can potentially
update our result so we'll check that
the length of this palindrome which we
can
compute by saying right minus left
plus one is greater
than our current result length
then we update the result
and we also have to not forget to update
the result length i usually forget to do
this
and let's also not forget to expand our
pointers outward so our left pointer
will be shifted to the left
our right corner will be shifted to the
right so now let's check the even
length palindromes as well
right now you can handle this a bunch of
different ways the way i'm going to do
it is
setting the left pointer to
i and setting the right pointer to i
plus one so again we're basically copy
and pasting the code that we just wrote
above
maybe we could write a function to do
this but that's
i'm too lazy to do that
so while it's a palindrome again we'll
check that
the length is we'll check that it's the
longest palindrome that we've seen so
far basically
if it is we update our result
and again we can expand our pointers
outward
and at the end all we have to do is
return
our result so i kind of made it look
easy
uh with the code but don't let it fool
you it took me a while to write this
before i started recording this
um there's a lot of like edge cases that
can be kind of annoying
with this problem i think for me putting
the if statement
uh checking that it's the longest
palindrome inside of the while loop
helped i think if you put this outside
the while loop it kind of makes it
harder
but i hope this at least gave you a
little bit of the intuition behind the
problem
writing the code is not always easy but
if this was helpful
leave a like and subscribe and thank you
for watching